ah yes don't push me that's the whole
thing don't push me dude I'm not on the
right I'm in the center but I'm just
saying dude
don't push me speaking of don't push me
here we go dude
I just saw this
help this woman DOA two A's at the end
heal from racial trauma now when I read
this headline I go like this okay
I understand trauma is real I suffer
from PTSD it makes my life a living hell
I am not ever really hit with racism I'm
a white guy mostly except for the past
few years because White's kind of took a
dip
I've been living pretty good now it's
harder to be a white guy than ever who
gives a [ __ ] man
I'm still rolling on my dolo and it's
fine okay but
you know especially in Hollywood it's
tougher so I'm not complaining I don't
give a [ __ ] give all the parts to all
people of color I don't care I want for
real there to be a movie about Buzz
Aldrin and a trans woman to play him
that I want that the biopic just like
one small step for wait a minute what do
we actually say I want that movie
and one giant well it's definitely a
giant leap for what we can't say mankind
I don't know anymore Flume Netflix just
the woke is [ __ ] so racial trauma I know
nothing about so let's take a gander I
don't look at this and go oh for [ __ ]
sake I'm not a boomer I look at this and
I say let's do some [ __ ] actually
let's take a comment we'll see what's
going on we'll come through this it's a
GoFundMe a lot of GoFundMe out there
from these out there are [ __ ] but
let's take a fun tooth comment look how
do this GoFundMe
let's see what that was all about
I don't deal with racism
hello
my name is DOA
I am now let's do the [ __ ] scale here
the the don't push me scale we start at
zero let's start at zero right [ __ ] and
then as it goes we'll see what the don't
push me scale is okay don't push me to
the right I'm a Centrist if you watch it
on YouTube we've got the don't push me
scale and it's my hand
we're starting at zero if you're
listening I feel like you'll probably
get the gist of what's going to be
happening during this bit
all I'm asking dowa
I get racial trauma I don't I don't get
racial trauma I get you get it and I'm
willing to understand that maybe you
need some [ __ ] bags for what happened
all I'm asking for is walk with me
and don't give me two right Wings where
I'm flying around in a circle getting
dizzy because I'm a Centrist
here's the scale and we start the
GoFundMe paragraph here how
has DOA I am a Nubian afro-indigenous
interdisciplinary artist
zeros here I did too many words okay I
don't even care about how you can be
whatever just too many words
but it's not bad we're at like a one or
a two now
and decolonial practice based researcher
currently residing on the stolen stolen
lands
of the
okay now this is what it says
X High w m upside down e eight k i w a y
upside down e m
what's a high W where's that W going hey
W get a little bit lower and bigger
[Laughter]
in parentheses must Queen never heard of
it that probably my privilege showing
let's pick it up with the left hand dude
oh dude hold on a second
there's another word I don't know s k
with the underlined regular WX with the
underline w u with an accent over it
the number seven
and then the word mesh in parenthesis
in parentheses swelling what tooth
peoples Colonial known as Vancouver dude
hair
[Applause]
foreign
so now we gotta start dude don't push me
but now we gotta start back at this is
not one this is we're at ten dude
because this ain't over [ __ ]
look the [ __ ] temperature burst all
right let me just read it
it's a really diff it's real it's really
difficult for me to ask for financial
support however I have exhausted all my
options and need my community's help
through my healing journey I work for a
charitable Arts organization and I am oh
you know what actually
we're going down
because I get it you went up a little
bit but let's take it down dude maybe
the thermometer didn't break
it's really difficult for me to ask for
financial support we feel you do it it's
a hard time so we're getting back down
however I have exhausted all my options
that's sad I'm in we're going back down
dude you get me back to Centrist very
good thank you DOA and need my community
to help through the healing Journey okay
we don't like the word healing journey
together but you know what we'll go up a
little bit but we're still here
uh I work for a charitable Arts
organization very admirable let's take a
dip dude we're getting back to one arm
getting back to zero aren't we uh and I
am initiating this GoFundMe because I'm
currently dealing with the impacts of
racial trauma what is it let's hang
tight right here for a second I
experienced at a work event which took
place on April 7th and 8th in 2022 now
you experienced racial trauma it proceed
now I got my [ __ ] detective [ __ ] on I
got my hat that that's got the front
bill and the back belt and I'm here with
a magnifying glass because if you
experience trauma on April 7th
what you doing
all good I don't know the issue let's
read on
the seventh I faced racist and
transphobic remarks from an artistic
director working in one of BC's school
districts on the 8th I witnessed a
culturally appropriated appointments
performance by a local non-black hip-hop
instructor who publicly humiliated me in
the black community after I highlighted
her lack of cultural and historical
context about hip-hop
foreign
where am I here
this had to be addressed as it could be
harmful for the children she educates in
school she admitted that her dance
school does not have a single black
instructor because they lack the 10
years of experience she's looking for my
employer took no action with either the
transphobic educator or the dance
instructor not even an email of
acknowledging was of acknowledgment was
sent to the colleagues in support of the
only black employee
I had a mental breakdown and left the
event early with permission from my
employer
only to later receive a text that the
staff photo was overlooked and was taken
without me wow
I was excluded which further alienated
me wow dude
you went home
additionally after this traumatic event
like we got to bend the whole thing
because this woman thinks we're trans I
don't know if she I don't know
additionally after this traumatic event
celebratory messages were shared
internationally about how successful the
event was completely dismissing my
trauma oh my God until I brought these
insensitive and hurt truth and hurtful
messages to their attention
okay there's more I don't want to read
it if you're bored go [ __ ] yourself
racial trauma has tremendously impacted
my mental and physical health in ways I
never experienced before
that sentence alone can live
you know I haven't been eating drinking
or sleeping well all right well
that's my sense of taste and smell
change oh
even food I used to enjoy smells
repulsive what have you found out later
she's pregnant
I have severe neck and shoulder pain
that I'm currently treating out of
pocket since my extended health coverage
to work has been exceeded
you have shoulder pain because of
a white guy doing hip-hop
I have suffered multiple anxiety attacks
in public which is why I limited
commuting on public transit and I'm
using Lyft Uber instead my ADHD symptoms
worsened as my brain feels extremely
overwhelmed trying to navigate ways to
cope with the trauma financial burden
and stress most of the time I have
extreme fear of leaving my apartment
unless I am with my friends it takes me
hours to play leaving I'm right with you
there but that's because of my OCD and a
lot of times I get so physically
exhausted from thinking and planning I
just give up and don't leave kwell
I recently completed my second ma degree
that resulted in me drowning in more
debt and student loans I intend on push
publishing my ma thesis apply for art
grants
complete our projects and more but
following this trauma I missed every
deadline
is there more
no
I expected to
expect it to is this a parody
it's real
thank you so much for everyone who
donated here and for e-transferred me
some funds I haven't posted an update in
a bit because I was waiting to hear back
some details from my employer also due
to my severe PTSD resulting from the
racial trauma I have physical symptoms
now every time I think of my workplace
gag nausea severe muscle pain one of the
triggers is my GoFundMe which is why it
took me some time to write an update
here uh
God see
what the [ __ ]
it's like this is the thing man
it's hard enough to deal with somebody
who has one problem this person has 10
problems and it is
expecting the world to bend to it we
can't do that because there's seven
billion people in the world dude if
there were 10 people this woman was in a
class and everyone was like we don't
know what to do with her just leave
there's seven people billion people in
this world if the world changes for you
it's [ __ ] for so many other people
dude put one step in front of the other
and I hate being like this but you push
I'm a Centrist
but you got to just get out there man I
know you're not asking for my advice but
you put it online dude she's got three
thousand dollars she made three thousand
dollars on her GoFundMe who's [ __ ]
donating I'm gonna donate for real
ah what what are you what can you
what can you say to these people it's a
mental condition huh I mean we all have
mental conditions I have mental
conditions I have OCD it's hard for me
do something to trigger my OCD some
things trigger my PTSD
I don't blame anybody about it you know
I try not to I at least try not to right
to get to the point where you're writing
a whole I wish people took
like none of this none of this is her
fault you know and I don't think you
should bully her or this is a comedy
podcast and I feel for this woman man I
just think that she you know people like
this might need some help
I don't feel for her because she got
racially traumatized I feel for her
because this [ __ ] she can't sit in a
class without finding a problem with it
like that she can't even be at home
without finding a problem this is a real
issue dude sometimes my OCD gets the
best of me and I stay in my [ __ ] bed
for a long time
I don't even think about blaming someone
else for that I mean yeah I blame other
people for lots of things like [ __ ]
you know
if I forget to bring water up to the
bedroom when I'm going to bed maybe it's
because my wife distracted me and that's
her fault
but I'm not starting to GoFundMe because
of it guys my wife distracted me when I
tried to go upstairs I needed water I'm
dealing with severe trauma in bed
because I don't want to go downstairs I
can't leave because she knows I have bad
OCD and I already set up for bed so I'm
up here and she wants me to go get water
for her but I was having the water and
then I put it down at the bottom of the
stairs because she asked me to clean the
dishes and you know the dishes were mine
but I cleaned them up and then when I
went upstairs I forgot to water I had
the water anyway I'm trying to get five
thousand dollars because I think that
that's what it's worth that I forgot the
water I woke up parched and my OCD was
absolutely flaming
my wife didn't go get it it resulted in
a [ __ ] uh you know a speed bump in my
marriage so it's like what the [ __ ] do I
do can people donate I probably could
get some money for that honestly I
definitely could get some money for that
if I was indigenous
I'm from the Sioux Tribe secretly
I think my adopted grandmother is Jewish
no no [ __ ] man
[Music]
the doctor was Jewish
um
I think I don't know people think [ __ ]
is crazy but also
there's so many [ __ ] things that are
so crazy out there in the world I just
can't believe it the internet [ __ ]
everything up didn't it crazy crazy
crazy
crazy congratulations
[Music]